discover with us the business management licenses
the most difficult to
have on the platform pathwayup
in fifth place
we find the double license
biomedical science and economics management
of the university
Paris cited with an access rate of seventeen percent
in 4th position
we find the Bachelor of Science and Management degree on a par
political science and relations courses
international
of the savoy mont-blanc university
and the Bachelor of Science in Management from the University
paris-est créteil val-de-marne
with an access rate of 12%.
arrives in 3rd position
tied with the double license
law and economics - university management
paris panthéon-assass
and the double degree in economics and management
and international management of the university
paris-est créteil val-de-marne
with an access rate of 11%.
in 2nd place on the
we find once again
a double degree in economics
management and management
international
university diploma management skills
of the university paris-est créteil val-de-marne
with an access rate of 10% this time
at the 1st place of this ranking
we find the economics and management license
economics and business management courses
of the University of Lille with an access rate of seven%.
for more content,
orientation and pathwayup
do not hesitate to subscribe